21h hier soir sous les étoiles
saint-piroise l'étincelle Juliette
Armanet mais le faux poudre
[Musique]
ses habits de lumière la grande Juliette
partage sans modération ces derniers
jours de disco avec son public avec
beaucoup beaucoup de générosité dans un
autre style le phénomène josman
[Musique]
et un record pour le rappeur avoir fait
péter les plombs de la scène salin par
deux fonds
enfin ambiance Copacabana avec une
habituée du Sakifo la Brésilienne Flavia
Coelho en mode 360 degrés
[Musique]
sans oublier les sublimes Nada Surf Kaf
Malbar les a Ducasse qui ont charmé les
15700 festivaliers une soirée éclectique
et sans faute